it just brings me back to the same
question dumb or diabolical are these
people stupid are they really
just actually the new york times evil it
makes them both
it really is yeah because they're
looking for views and clicks and like
ode is not going to get you the hits
that paid is going to get you right
sadly not but i don't that doesn't mean
they did it
intentionally so what do we do as
citizens
because this is not going to change this
is only going to get worse
as alexander dugan said on my podcast
the other day said there's no fact
there's only information
yeah so what do we are to do as
individuals moving forward in this
universe where we're being bombarded by
things that are 750 dollars true
billion also true one thing what do we
do is acknowledge when you're wrong
at least on a personal no no i mean what
do we do as the recipients of this
information how do we make sense of the
world
stuff like this at least partly yes this
is called sense making what we're doing
because at least at least the the option
is voting works
and you know what's really funny is like
i wouldn't have said that in 2015 or 16
and then donald trump won and started
laughing i'm like i guess voting works
they're freaking out they're like
burning the house down because they hate
trump so much
clearly voting works go vote that's the
most important thing
and no confrontations like they're so
hungry for
any right winger to slip up so they can
smear and say that's it
i think i think it's hilarious when they
were like well i can't remember what i
was reading it was about
uh antifa tearing down this abraham
lincoln statue and there was a comment
saying we know it's actually the proud
boys i'm like there's no proud boy
tearing down
abraham lincoln dude that's just not
happening why would they
why would the left tear down the statue
of abraham lincoln when he was the last
president to nominate a supreme court
justice
you know like in an election year like
remember they had to go all the way back
to abraham lincoln
abraham lincoln to come up with some bs
story about the supreme court nomination
in abraham lincoln because
uh he was he was a a president during
expansion
he was an expansionist westward
expansion colonialist yes
and he was stealing land from the
indigenous he was a republican too
you know it's crazy yeah i saw uh this
progressive friend of mine posted this
thread about how
you could no longer call los angeles
like la or something
because it's like the spanish name is no
the native american it's like a shanghai
or something
or something i don't know how they're
gonna say los angeles is like a cultural
appropriation of this spanish phrase
oh yeah yeah you know the actual name of
la is it's like this ridiculously long
thing oh really yeah you can
can you can you wikipedia yeah it's in i
didn't know this i don't know how you
guys feel about while you're looking
that up
um columbus day because i think columbus
was a psychopath
and we got taught a lot of like first of
all you got to be a psychopath to get on
a boat to sail off the edge of the true
first definitely and then you have to be
a psychopath to manage
the gang of guys that are going to be
willing to do such a thing yeah right
other psychopaths yes right exactly cut
me off at any time lady if you find what
la's
oh yeah we found it we're looking at it
right now yeah i got it through
yeah i can't pronounce this in spanish
wait why is my mic not on oh
it's uh the actual name of la is el
pueblo de nuestra senora la rena de los
angeles del rio
oh town of our lady the queen of angels
of the river porch and gula
oh and portugal is the native
i don't know how you guys feel about
changing to indigenous people's day
because like he would he had his two
brothers and they took
i think it was the dominican republic is
that where they they set up their
governorship
yes and basically we're just beating
people on the street his brothers would
drag women by the hair down the road and
like rape them
i've i've heard too many different
stories yeah so i just i just don't care
i heard that he was actually punished
for the cruelty
when he when he returned to europe and
he got criminal charges and i've heard a
whole bunch of others
so i'm just like you know what man it's
what we're dealing with right now and
and the reason why
i find this censorship and this biden
stuff so scary historical revisionists
the statues are being torn down right
now it's not a joke
this is this this is their revolution no
one is stopping them they keep doing it
they've been doing it and they started
with confederates and and
and you know it's it's it's so it's so
amazing how much it's like
they they it's on purpose they know that
no one's really going to defend
confederates
like dude personally i think the
confederate flag you put them in
the confederate statues you put them in
a museum we put up a plaque we explain
our history and all stuff
make sure people remember and they can
learn the history then they're like okay
now we're gonna tear down thomas
jefferson because you know he had slaves
and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
thomas jefferson was a lot of things but
we cherish the good not the bad
no then they tear down george washington
then they tear down hans christian heg
a union soldier who died fighting to
free the slaves and a
abolitionist and that was his his claim
to fame that's it
he was like 30 years old he said we
gotta abolish this i will die to free
slaves and then he did
and they tore his statue down frederick
douglass gets torn down literally dude
was a slave
and then worked on the underground
railroad and fought legislatively and
physically to free the slaves amazing
dude
they tear statues here's two two little
stories about how this has progressed
and how quickly
in 2014 they were doing some statue
stuff but it was probably like some kkk
guy at the time and i was like
where is this going to go are we going
to be tearing down statues with
washington one day i said this on my
facebook page this is like 2014.
everybody freaked out they thought i was
a maniac for it
second thing is i went to santa fe a
couple years ago santa fe new mexico i
was invited to speak at the university
of new mexico when i was doing a book
tour for democrat to deplorable
amazon.com by the way democrats are
deplorable there we go i'm a media
professional
and they actually banned me as i'm
flying
on my way to new mexico so i i don't
actually get to speak there because
there was a hubbub
so i do a tour we go to santa fe i was
in albuquerque and we go to santa fe
and in the middle of the town they have
this 1869 monument
and it was questionable because it would
involve like killing indians and all
kinds of stuff and there's a plaque
and it said like oh they use words like
savage and rebel and whatever
on this monument it's on dispute you
know tempers were high times have
changed we've grown and evolved whatever
whatever
and i took a picture of it then 2018 i
was like look this is how we should
handle disputed monuments
right put a plaque next to it explain
what happened show our progression as
people as humans as a society
and guess what they just tore down they
tore on that very freaking
statue just like two days ago a monument
to the union soldiers
yeah they crossed out apparently like
the word savages or whatever yeah and
and left it up as a monument to the
union soldiers who died and slavery
well they tried on abraham lincoln so
that finally happened why
well the guy who literally signed the
emancipation proclamation
he gets torn down and teddy roosevelt
because they're expansionists
teddy roosevelt apparently said some
offensive things about native americans
yeah he killed a lot of them
yeah yeah so they they tear him down
they hit him he was an empire builder he
was kind of like a trump
trump people hated him loved him and
hated him yeah he was an empire
a lot of love at the time a lot of love
this is what scares me
it's the revisionism it's the it's the
fake
you know everything you have done is bad
and they ignore everything else
as it's like how far back do we go how
far back do we go to figure out who gets
what
because the native americans fought for
land too you know
they bought each other they were vicious
against each other and i'm not and i'm
not saying
that anything the colonists who came to
this country did was good i'm just
saying where are we now what could we do
to make everything better
how do we how do we make that rising
tide raise all ships are we going to do
it by burning things down and screaming
no we're not the logical conclusion of
this is that we just give
everything back to the trees okay no no
no naturalism
i think you're what came what was the
first thing on land it wasn't trees was
it was it trees
i have no idea fungus probably yeah
yes definitely no no no i don't think so
i think that i think trees came way way
after land animals
it was something else i was reading i
was reading
no no on land i was reading something
that was like
i was reading something that was like uh
trees are actually millions of years
younger than like some specific land
critters or something
oh wow like there were other plants here
and algae was you know oxygen oxygen of
fine or whatever
coral coral is an animal which is odd
maybe there was land coral yeah
i don't know about that just throwing
stuff it wouldn't be able to move around
but
what do we give it back to like how do
we repair
and move forward without destroying
everything
well you just recognize in the
fundamental human rights and you you
move forward
it's as simple as that fundamental human
rights are human rights universal
does every human in the in on the planet
have the same
human rights does every culture have the
same notion of rights
different question yeah i believe that
we have been bestowed by our creator
inalienable
rights indeed they're endowed upon us uh
i'm actually not 100 i'm just saying you
know that's basically what we said in
the usa and the was it the declaration
of independence yeah
and uh the rights are granted to us not
uh by by
just the fact that we exist not by a
king or a government
that's not true for other cultures right
yeah and that's why they don't like us
so much is because we declare that those
are universal
yep yeah and if they're universal that
means if you haven't adopted them that
means that you're doing it wrong
but human slang it puts us in a position
of conflict this is what the outs this
is what the rest of the world thinks
right they have their own their own
civilizations and their own cultures and
their own morals and their own
idea of human values and then they hear
us saying hey ours are universal buddy
and if you don't take them you're in big
trouble thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you